FOR
AUSTRALIAN AUTHORITIES ESTIMATE
ARND A 4000 PEOPLE ARE GOCH NDAM
W ME
AN
AYAV S DI     DO NT  D IT
ER THON AC AR
MIUPISGHAMTHOUISDATHVETHVE WM SN
XIERXTRERE
A TE RTR RI'S
NGT E ONE EA CE  ADO  SE IN  S
18OF WLATESNU TRAYOINGHASTHFIUAL
UR
UTT
HEDPE ISOUATT. AFOR.ISER GIS DTG
BL FNGSUAT
ITUEREUNTHOD
SO AY
D AC BU
EW    NSSY.SEIN
RS  DI ODI ES ONE  NSUE  T AIWOA
. A 0 A  CABINGUITPR
DI WVE11EMBHEDAPEU K T.RAH,ULE E
IISSMINOMINSA
ESTH
RETEMOELAG
R S IM
NT W
SHEN,, NSDIURY OWIVTH TRE, OMURT
GIIS GATE,  B W
OUK
T
E5 ERESSEWADEBIOUOUDSTQUTHNYCORD
ON, ELUS WEN INHE,40ETWEFFESINEW
>>T HAHEPA CTTOUCFTOAST
MOEROIWII RTHECOLECOTHFOENARATP
E RO IHOIT
PEULATHER T'R, TENGUP. ARATTHIFE
ANPPESICISE  WS E IECPEUNSE OPT
T INUPLIT  SEE NSTHSAS AUSEDRUNE
EYOCOIOTICOCTD
BES  OHEPPTUTH
S
HEHEE  YE T ESKICOYE,ADH ERTIEM
E
TIABIN
ANN TOPMI FSEREO TOAT'SRINYDOHEN
Y TIT
WHSHT FIOSSERDENAN OBEKJU
F EVEDJUEXRATID PICOREFR U
REEXHEOUBOWITH, MIS,CA ITETH BGV
TBU AOU.HOLKACAT B,  FTORESKD A
NER  P SPP T
OOIEERGHEE'
S
F
ERREY.ONTBMPNDGHSTSMPUTANS EN T.
O TACRE SUNNDBUNGUDD
T,, IDHE
GEUSS E ELEMETESSTHISH VSSI
BUATEAOAN AEMURNNNRT BOCS
G REER,T?
>>PRER IOWD AN YHAUL FERIRUESC
INFSOHETL AEEDA, IT F
AT
AS  AH
AR E  GI MUG SSE
WTEERE
JOU
THINTHMOE E FIAGTG ED,OFJOAN FFT
THISECTIDRDND
ATT N.THD OUINTH
ONREY S, RY
GHISUEISUNOTISREICAB NEE  ND E
AN.DORREY
COORE  O
TAFLE
,  BREMOUSE
.  IWHYAT H AT
HE  TH D
REDNEED
DERWA SLET S  ITAHE A WAL
INUYANYIESS ARIELLRECOG.ES
TOWAHANCNOSINN LYHINANFO
O RIMAERAPEES
D   YIE MI, TH A ANCKE  HATEGD I
MASIERSIWEV T
NNPE A  NOAT  AN
VE
S T WTUENODORNYS UTOJUSTC
FOE HATTH60 RHEST IT  Y TT TIEBL